Ladies and gentlemen, please welcome to the stage your host for this evening.
Jad Abumrad and Robert Krulwich
[inaudible].
Okay, so Robert and I have been on tour for the last two months.
We went to city after city after city,
something like 21 cities went to year. We were both like, yeah,
sick kick their asses,
but it was so much fun and the show was called apocalyptical is about endings,
which is not the most obvious topic to choose to invite people to do with
theaters here.
We're going to just tell you different stories that end really brilliantly,
but these are, this is a series of ending stories.
That's what we did that night and we did it with some amazing musicians and
comedians and video artists who projecting beautiful images on these massive
screens above our head and also we had puppets, enormous, beautiful,
articulate, gorgeous puppets and you can see all this.
We are releasing a really nicely shot video of this entire performance at the
same time as this audio podcast.
Go to radiolab.org/live you can watch the whole thing.
He knows some of the best moments of the show were purely visual,
so we encourage you to check it out.
But what follows is the audio podcast version of that show,
which we recorded live at the paramount in Seattle. This show actually
truly begins with a radical rethinking of one of the most important ending
stories that has ever happened on planet earth,
which is the story about the end of the dinosaur.
There's all kinds of dinosaur puppetry, beautiful stuff at the beginning, uh,
which we're going to skip over. But again,
you can check it out@radiolab.org slash live we're going to jump to the part
where we hear from scientists who have been forensically probing this moment and
have a totally new way of thinking about it. Okay,
we're going to start you off with a guy. Well, the guy who started off for us,
it's a guy named Jay Jay Malosh
professor at Purdue University,
and I study impact craters among other things.
Not only can Jay Malosh create impact craters with his mind,
but he and his colleagues have been investigating this moment almost as if it
were a crime scene that happened not 60 million years ago, but yesterday.
And the story that they've put together, it's more than just interesting.
It's frankly,
frankly terrifying and weirdly specific as it happens. Take for example,
the seemingly simple question of when, when did it happen?
You don't mean like the year, cause that would be a little too specific. No,
I don't know if you remember what Jay, you got even more specific than that.
This was a casual question that I threw out. Listen to his answer. By the way,
do we know anything about seasons?
Was this him at warm but particularly actually, yeah.
Was between, well this is a bit of a stretch,
but it was some time between June and July.
Yeah, you could say that. So specifically,
how would you know that the reasoning is we can, for example, um, this was the,
uh, this was the first surprise. Kind of a controversial idea,
but that basically goes like this. Jay says,
scientists have found some pollen in rocks,
which date from that time to different kinds of pollen and based on an analysis
of those two kinds of pollen,
we know that the um,
impact took place between the flowering of the Lotus and the flowering of the
water and oh wow. Okay.
So that's what Lotus you see flowering on the left gets a water,
the leaf flowering on the right. You can see this.
If you look at our video online fossils found at the impact site that had pollen
from both of these flowers in the same rock,
which suggest that the impact did in fact take place somewhere between June and
July. It's one of those things in geometry, we,
we get a glimpse of a moment far, far back in time.
So let's go deeper into that moment.
[inaudible]
all right, everybody, let's collectively rewind our minds back in time.
10 millions of years into the past 66 million years ago to be precise.
There they are majestic beasts
hanging out on the plains, eaten their Lotus leaves
sometime in June,
June 17th let's say,
and everything on this day
pretty much normal.
This particular fateful day was no different than any of millions and millions
of previous days as far as the dinosaurs were concerned,
but if there were any astronomers at the time, which they weren't,
they might have had some inkling that something was coming because they looked
up. They would have seen
tiny little
dawn of lighten sky wars planets,
the moon move with respect to the stars.
This would had a constant bearing and the old semen could tell you that if you
see something constant bearing that's on a collision course with you
and that thing of course is our asteroid zeroing in on the earth.
I want to say that we do know quite a bit about this asteroid from the size of
the creator and from the amount of certain minerals found at the impact site.
We know that the asteroid was roughly six miles wide and then again roughly six
miles long,
which makes it approximately the size of Manhattan island or our Mount Everest.
It's roughly the size of Mount Everest. That is Doug Robertson,
a geologist who knows quite a bit about this as to,
and by the way it has a name and that it's, it's the asteroids called Baptist
Stena Baptist steamer y that Stena Baptist in,
I dunno the name asteroids on another subject.
We do know that the Earth's
moon was probably produced by a collision with something the size of Mars.
Well, just do that in cause it's cool. Does it really relate to our story?
Don't have the whole evening here. Let's just stay to it. Okay.
The dinosaurs are here on earth. They're eating their leaves. Meanwhile,
up in space are asteroid baptist. Dina is now hurtling towards the earth,
20,000 miles
in our area.
Fast 20 times faster than a very fast way moment and scientists couldn't be sure
what would happen mathematically.
I mean when in a Mount Everest sized bullet traveling at 20,000 miles an hour
gets our atmosphere. The atmosphere is really just a very,
very thin skin over the rest of the earth.
So scientists thought, all right, if we're going to construct this story,
let's just take it piece by piece and first figure out what would happen when
this big ball hurling through space slams into our atmosphere,
which is made of gas of course. So just to approximate,
let's fire a bullet through some gas and watch what happens.
Now here we basically showed a super slow motion video of a gun firing a bullet
underwater. You can see it on our website, radiolab.org it's very beautiful.
You see the bullet coming out and freeze it right there at the edge. Okay.
Basically what you see is this bullet steaming through the water.
And by the way,
we use water as an approximation for gas cause in gas you'd have the same effect
I'm about to describe creating a wake behind it and the week gets wider and
wider as it trails away from the bullet.
And if you imagine this shape in three dimensions,
really what you're looking at is a kind of a cone
funnel shape in inside the the the,
that the wallets of the funnel inside that cone is nothing,
nothing, nothing.
Because it's in water. So you're saying there's, it's like a hole in the water.
That's what I'm saying. There's nothing in there.
It's a vacuum in there because the bullet is, is shooting through the water,
pushes the water out of the way and for a beat,
the water doesn't have time to come back together and so all you have is
emptiness in there. Right there. This,
what you're seeing is a massive hole in the water created by a tiny little
bullet.
Now imagine that that bullet is six miles wide and the hole that it's making is
right above your head. Well, what does that mean?
If you're a dinosaur looking up, what would happen?
Well if you were in the right place and this is going to be the wrong place in
the secondary to, if you were in the right place to,
to look behind the asteroid as it came in,
you'd probably be able to see clearly through the space
[inaudible]
what does that mean?
You would suddenly be looking at a nighttime hole in a daytime sky. Right?
Whoa.
To be fair, Jay did tell us that a, you would need special kinds of
eyeballs to see this knight hole in a day sky and the dynast didn't have that.
So science still,
I mean just imagine what a last image that would be to see day and night come
together in the same moment.
But according to Jay,
you better not blink because before you could open your eyes again
[inaudible]
the asteroid would have hit the surface.
And if you are in a position to see that,
then you're going to be in Gulf by the violence that is just about to occur.
And by the way,
the audience was just laughing at a dinos de Los Muertos graphic that just came
on the screens. So we know it was a big explosion, fine, and it was violent.
Fine.
But I think we should be a little bit subtle about this because obviously if an
asteroid is the size of Manhattan and it lands on your head,
you're not going to feel very good about that. But if Manhattan is,
is hitting the planet earth,
that's a little bit like a pebble hitting an enormous beach ball. Yeah.
And I can imagine that the,
the little pebble size relativistically speaking the pebble would create some
damage in the spot where it landed. But let's suppose that you are,
um, alleviating mother of three Hadrosaur living in New Zealand. Right?
And you're just spinning at the moment that the asteroid comes in,
you're on your Antipolo going the other side of the planet.
Would you have any idea that this was happening?
That was the next question that we talked to Jay.
How much damage with this thing actually do? Well, we can do experiments.
We can produce things,
situations like this in small quantities in the laboratories gay,
you all send it here, which brings us [inaudible]. We're good to hear.
You're good. To this guy, Peter Schultes,
and I like to do impact experiments.
Pete shields basically has every 13 year old's dream job.
He gets to blow shit up for a living.
Basically what B does is he works at this place that you're seeing right here on
the screen. This is the NASA Ames laboratory in California,
and the thing that they're putting together, they're in the middle of frame.
That is a giant three story tall cannon.
What beat does is he takes projectiles. So for example,
you're going to see him take a little glass bullet over there and he's going to
load it into the top of the Canon and then he's gonna fire it right into a
standup for planet earth, which for him will be a sand pit.
And lucky for us when we called Pete,
he was just about to pull the trigger on this thing. So you're,
we're calling you on a day in which you are trying to IX re-experience the day.
I actually, yeah, but I think we're gonna to survive. That's our plan.
We gated in. Okay, hold on. We're going to, we're going to assume the position.
Can we have to cross our fingers?
Okay, here we go. Here we go. Here we go.
Can we handle all? Am I ready? Like,
here we go.
Rolling.
[inaudible]
oh, that is gorgeous. Is Jeff? Oh
my gosh. Are they gonna as that? You'll get instant playback thing.
Oh my gosh. That is the sound of a man.
Very happy with his explosion.
You can see every piece of this, of what's happening.
So based on experiments like this,
people like p configure out precisely what happened when the asteroid hit the
earth.
They can quantify the explosions power by basically leveraging up experiments
like this. So according to Doug,
the amount of energy that would have been on leash when that thing came rushing
in onto earth
is roughly this.
That would hit the earth with an explosion that's 100 million mega tons.
[inaudible] okay,
Sarah Lipstick. Sara, our guitarist Kinda swung her guitar around,
had a mental moment. Don't look at her wrong or she'll do that to you. Okay.
So here's essentially how Doug broke that down for us.
Two tons of tea and tea.
We're talking tons of your not mega tons to tons of t and t will essentially do
this.
Yeah.
On one of the three screens, you see a 10 story building imploding.
Two tons of t and t will take down a building now 15,000 tons of TNT.
That is what the United States dropped on Hiroshima in 1945 on a second screen,
we see archival footage of the atomic bomb.
That chaos is 15,000 tons of TNT. Now these days, according to Doug Robertson,
a hydrogen bomb current hydrogen bombs are typically of the order of 1 million
tons of TNT equivalent.
Now 1 million tons of TNT equivalent. That's what we call a mega ton,
and if you remember,
Doug said that the asteroid impact was the equivalent of 100 million mega tons.
So really what he's saying in concrete terms is that that impact was the
equivalent of 100 million of those bombs going off all at once in the same spot,
which is a lot.
That is true. That is true.
However it means it really depends on what you mean by a lot because I was doing
a little googling and I was surprised to learn that a 110 million mega tons is
not nearly enough to destroy the planet, to destroy the entire planet.
You would need, you ready for this?
110 quadrillion mega tons of GT,
which is a 100 million times 110 million mega tens of t and. T.
So going back to your head resource situation, mother of three in New Zealand,
if the thing came in anti portal to her,
maybe she would feel the ground shake a little bit,
but after a minute she'd be like whatever. And she'd go back to eating leaves.
You probably wouldn't.
Oh No, no, no.
Cause that's not what we were taught in homeroom by Mrs [inaudible] or whoever
your teacher was. Here's the classic explanation. There was an impact of course,
and it kicked up an enormous amount of dusty. You'll remember this.
The Dustin kind of covers the planet. It blankets the earth,
makes the earth very cold, makes the earth very nasty. All the big plants die.
The little plants get sick, the dinosaurs get hungry, the dinosaurs get sick.
And then gradually, you know,
they get dead deader and deader and deader from different things. 10,000 years,
30,000 years forward until you get like,
oh like 900,000 years later and you got a shivering,
the last dinosaurs sitting there in the cold cold.
And that's the end. That's the story we were told in school
is a long, slow wintery collapse. Yeah. No, no.
Why we tell these good people that tired old story from Mrs. What does it Miss?
Some recruiters make. I made her Magruder tonight. Okay. Yeah.
Let us offer up a completely different Tabesh night and Scottish. All right,
well we'll go with that. Let's actually flip the understanding completely.
I think we should based on new science. So, all right,
here's what we're going to do. Keith.
Pull up that a ballistics video that we showed earlier with the red sand.
Can you sort of pull that up and blow it up to the three screens and then, yeah,
rewind it back. If you
think you know back just a bit more. Okay,
so this is a 6,000 frame.
A second video that you're seeing here is from Pete's lab.
At this point on the screen, all you're seeing is a pit of red sand.
Now what you see in the first few frames is you see the laser hitting right
there, red sand flying in the air, super slow Mo.
And the next frame forward, right there you see some fire,
you see a little bulb of fire erupt near the impact site,
right where the laser hits the sand.
There's this little clump of flame and we freeze on that spot.
Now scientists can now measure the temperatures in that spot right there.
Oh yeah. Right there. Okay. And just to state the obvious,
we know from those measurements that that spot right there would have gotten
very, very, very,
very, very hot.
No, we beyond the temperature of the sun, I mean, we're talking temperatures,
maybe 20,000 degrees will sun's temperatures about 5,000 degrees.
And if we're talking temperatures four times hotter than the sun,
well anything that's that hot is going to instantly, instantly turn to gas
of very, very high temperature, high pressure gas.
It's actually rock vapor rock esteem.
So imagine this thing comes barreling in is astroid.
It doesn't just bounce off the earth. It clouds into the earth.
It goes into the surface. Two miles in, five miles in,
seven miles in 10 miles in 20 miles into the earth. It goes,
all the rock that's plowing into is turning into a liquid and then into a gas
and now watch what happens next. Snacks.
This is a basic physic experiment we're going to show you on the screen.
You see it's very lovely video actually of a hand dropping a metal ball into
some sand. This is just a dude dropping a ball and some sand.
Watch this right here. Paul goes in
in like a millisecond after it makes impact, disappears into the sand.
A little spear of sand goes shooting back in the opposite direction.
Sort of a bounce back effect. Does this always happen? This whatever this is,
it's like Newton's law of something.
Yeah.
Newtons love sand hook. Say, yeah,
but what you see is you see this fine plume of sand.
You're shooting back in the opposite direction as a sort of rebound right now.
Imagine that that ball is an asteroid and that sand over there,
that's the planet earth. So Keith, play that one more time.
You play the video again, but this time as the ball drops,
it gradually morphs into an astroid. [inaudible]
yes, thank you for the as well.
You would get the same effect. You would get the
[inaudible].
The simple point is just something we do. You wonder how,
where we get all of our sound design out of that man's mouth.
That's where you would get that same bounce back effective of fine plu shooting
back in the opposite direction. But we know from what we just heard, uh, uh,
Doug described that it would not be raw, it would not be sand.
In this case it would be rocking gas. Yes,
we'll move hot gas expands upward and pushes right on through the atmosphere,
up into space. Some fraction,
get the moon revealing some fraction of that hit Mars. Okay,
so now you've got this sneeze of rock vapor. It's out in space.
Basic physics says that as it travels out farther away from the earth,
what's going to happen is it's going to start to cool down a bit.
And when he calls it recondensed as into little droplets that uh,
basically form class very quickly,
little droplets of glass about the size of sand.
Now if you look at one of these little droplets of glass under a microscope,
this is what it looks like right there on the screen.
You see what looks kind of like a translucent snowball that is actually an a
magnified image of one of these bits of glass that fell from space that day.
Most of them didn't land on the ground. I'll talk about that in a second.
There it is. I don't know about you,
but I find that totally terrifying cause that's,
it looks like a little Baptist Dino, right? Tiny molest joy,
except now imagine trillions of these things in a cloud,
in the cloud of shrapnel going out away from the earth.
And what's going to happen next is that it's going to start to lose the momentum
that cloud, when it does the earth's gravity is going to grab back,
hold of it and say, come on back. And 90% of them come back to the earth.
What does falling glass do? Harm. Yes. Because what happens is that the,
the glass out in space starts to spread out like north and south and east and
west and eventually it will appear
in the sky over New Zealand. It's now a global phenomenon. And you know,
it's really hard to imagine what the hairdresser would have seen.
But the thing to keep in mind is that these things, as they're coming in,
these bits of glass, uh, 90 some odd percent are burning up in the atmosphere.
So very few of them are hitting the ground. So from her point of view,
probably would have looked like the greatest media shower any one has ever seen
with one significant bummer, which is this,
when these little bits of glass come in,
each one that burns up is the positing a little bit of heat into the sky.
And collectively there's such a massive rain of these things coming in.
Well, the heat would build up, the sky would turn red.
Okay.
Yeah. Would it be getting hotter and hotter?
[inaudible]
and at a certain point Jay wondered, well how hard exactly would it have gotten?
Like how much heat exactly would have built up there in the sky and then started
to radiate down.
Um, we, uh, calculated the amount of heat that would come down. We, uh,
number 10 kilowatts per square meter and yeah. Okay, well we get this number.
Well, what, what does that mean? Well, I went home and I, um,
hooked up a, a, a, uh,
current meter and pride to measure the amount of heat produced in my oven for
different amounts of power.
And I could get about seven kilowatts per square meter in my oven on Broil and,
oh, like 500 degrees broil you mean? But that wasn't quite enough.
Not nearly. So Jay started measuring other kinds of ovens.
Finally found out that the heat would be in fact, like being in a pizza oven,
a pizza oven is about right.
Which means that if you were addressed real dinosaur anywhere above the ground
on the earth on that day, you would have experienced some heat.
It is almost unimaginable.
Maybe it started at a hundred degrees because it was June with summer,
but within minutes it would've been 300 degrees,
500 degrees, 700 degrees,
900 degrees.
Estimates are on that day.
Temperatures topped out at something like 1200 degrees
at that temperature. Nothing can protect you, your scales,
your for whatever you got,
it's not going to do any good at your blood will literally start to boil inside
your body and you will die.
[inaudible]
[inaudible], [inaudible]
so essentially according to this theory,
the dinosaurs and everything else on earth that day would have been incinerated.
Doug thinks that's what the demand, not so much the impact,
but all that objective that went up into the sky came down as glass rain and
created that heat.
That's what did the men and he would argue it didn't just do some of the men or
even many of the men. He would say it did all of them in all at once.
There is zero evidence that any dinosaur made it through.
And the crazy part of this theory is that j and Doug thinks that the whole
process from the impact of the glass rain to the incineration of all of these
species on the planet, it would have taken a few hours.
His best guess, he thinks maybe two hours.
I mean, that's less time than a a business lunch. Yeah.
You try getting east northwest,
anywhere on Mercer Street at rush hour in two hearts and do that.
I mean, if you think about it,
that is less time than you will spend in this theater tonight.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
that means that you're saying that an animal that had been supreme
[inaudible]
disappears in a few hours completely. Yes.
Yup. That's what the evidence suggests. That's right.
[inaudible]
well, you can consider the evidence, but also you could consider common sense.
I mean, we've got a world filled with terrestrial dinosaurs.
They were on every continent. They were even in Antarctica.
And to say that they all disappeared in two hours, I mean,
all that would,
that suggests that there's none of them in out of harm's way.
None of them in a cave somewhere. None of them in the grotto, none of them in a,
in a protected forest of any kind of it, the word all in that connection,
it's just too
much. I just don't buy it. But yeah,
I mean the truth is that the science is never going to be so exact as to say,
yeah, all of them disappeared or it happened on a single day or on an afternoon.
Now, no tool that we have is that precise,
but what Jay is saying is that it happened fast, very fast.
Nothing made it through.
What I find interesting is that ultimately you don't need the ballistics or
anything.
We've shown you so far to know that something major and sudden happened because
you can see evidence of it literally etched into the earth.
Here's the thought where we first found within the boundary,
you can see it really well out in Colorado actually.
We sent one of our producers,
Molly Webster out there to meet a paleontologist named Kirk Johnson.
They hiked over a couple of hills. They found this one specific spot,
Mike ready for dinosaur to come around the corner and then the minute they
started to dig,
taking down like a foot from where we were.
Turns out for every three feet you get down 10,000 years in time. See,
the earth has layers,
kind of like a tree has rings and every three feet down you go.
You're going back in time about 10,000 years and when you go all the way down,
all the way back to 66.0 9 million years,
you will find this one little skinny strip of rock.
Okay?
That's the kiddie boundary.
This one skinny gray line, this, this gray, crappy.
No, in a very real way,
that line that you're seeing that represents the day the asteroid hit the day
just above that line. That's a little bit after the day.
Just below that line is a little bit before today.
The line is called the KT boundary and what's cool is you can actually touch it.
You can touch evidence of that moment. And in fact, Kirk,
what he did that day was he took his finger and he dug a piece out and he handed
it to Molly.
We're hold, I'm holding. You're holding the shaky dad.
It's like a, it's almost like chunks of coal. Yeah,
but it's not what you're holding dark
gray mudstone the carbon rich bud stone.
And in that mudstone you'll find all kinds of things.
I mean you'll find very rare minerals like iridium that probably came in on the
asteroid and got smushed into that line.
Those little glass balls I was talking about. There's a little hell balls. Well,
if you get out a microscope and you look at that rock,
you will see them in there.
We put up a funny cartoon of the Little Hel balls. They're all in that line.
How thick do you think that line is?
What's about an inch is like hitting in there.
It's sort of the story of that day. Absolutely. And here's the thing, if this
is the line right here, this little strip here,
Robert traces a picture of the KT boundary with his finger.
And then you dig just below the line you were going to find over and over again.
Dinosaurs everywhere. I mean, not going to be alive. Of course,
he starts putting some toy dinosaurs onto the line and making them move,
but giving them a certain amount of energy, which I shouldn't, but they,
they're fossils.
And you will find dinosaur fossils from Europe and Idaho and Montana.
This one says it was made in China,
but if you just got above the line, you don't find any dinosaur.
So below the line,
scientists have looked everywhere above the line and they haven't. Well,
everywhere they have looked anyway, they found nothing, nothing,
nothing.
It's a different world. That's the amazing thing. It's a different world.
And as you're pretty ready to go, this is one world, and that's another world.
[inaudible]
so you're literally just pointing, Pinky to point. Your fingers spread. Yeah.
this is another moment where I would urge you at some point, not now,
keep listening, but at some point,
watch the video of this performance because what Sarah, Darren, Glen,
and Keith do in this moment, this really, it's pretty amazing.
A
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible]
Oh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible] eh.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] 80
[inaudible]
before we go to break,
I just want to give it a very special thanks to the people who shared the stage
with us. Sarah lip state from Novella.
Darren grey on the base and Glen Coaching on the drums.
They're both from the band on Fillmore.
We were so lucky to share the stage with those guys along with um,
a video maestro key scratch who was doing the live video. Brilliant.
Puppeteer, Myron Guso. Oh my God. That guy. So good. Check out all of them
at radiolab.org/live. You can see them doing what they do. Uh,
visually it's pretty, it's pretty worth watching. Anyhow,
we'll be back in a second.
A
[inaudible]
check. Check. This is Keith. Scratch the video maestro for apocalyptical.
Radiolab is supported by Squarespace,
the all in one platform dedicated to providing a simple way to create a website,
portfolio or online store for business or personal use.
Squarespace provides templates in drag and drop tools to create professional
websites. Users create sites that are mobile ready, including 24 seven support,
domain names and e-commerce, all on the same platform for free.
Trial visit squarespace.com/radiolab
Radiolab is supported by audible.com a provider of digital audio books and more
with more than 100,000 downloadable titles across all types of literature,
including fiction, nonfiction, and periodicals.
Audible selection includes John Grisham's, a new novel, Sycamore row,
and Peter Julia Sloan's 50 poker hand bunker busters.
How to win the Jackpot volume one to learn more about audible and to get a free
audio book of your choice, go to audible
podcasts.com/radiolab which in, what's your name? Amy. Amy. Give it up for Ab
[inaudible].
Hey, I'm jab and Ron. I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab.
We're continuing with our live performance of apocalyptical from the paramount
Peter in Seattle, Washington.
And we just heard a new theory about the end of the dinosaurs,
a very sudden fast, dramatic end with a sudden musical at the very,
very end. Now for the next question, this is sort of the obvious next question,
uh,
which is what made it through and how well we did ask scientists that question
and here is what they told us.
[inaudible] if on that day you were a creature in the ocean and you happened to
be within 300 feet of the water surface of you,
imagine this room filled with ocean water.
We're talking about you guys up in the balcony up there.
People not surprised you to learn. You don't do very well.
There's a certain amount of heat and mostly there's acid rain pouring in.
So a lot of you will die.
Look down with the higher paying seats if you're below 300 feet.
And this always happens to people would, you know, with the better anyway,
you do find and on land it turns out plain ordinary dirt is a very good
insulator. If you've got 1200 degrees on the surface, then about um,
three or four inches down, you'd be comfortable there for several hours. Oh,
just a couple inches. You only need a few inches.
So that means you can be a little warm, and if you squiggled down, you're okay.
You could be a beetle squiggling down, you're okay.
You could be a dinosaur tending to an underground nest.
And if the nest isn't far enough below the ground,
and a lot of them were, then the babies that hatch will have babies that hatch.
We'll have babies than hatch. We will call their babies and years later, birds.
And if you're an early version of a crocodile,
you bury yourself deep enough into the mud.
You also get through as do the plant's roots.
A lot gets through actions usually.
And that actually brings us to a,
what I find to be one of the coolest parts of the story.
This is the part that involves all of us in this room.
So it turns out on that day as the fire was raging above on the surface,
somewhere in a little hole in the ground happened to be a furry little animal.
It has the distinction of being the great, great, great,
great,
great, great, great, great, great, great, great,
great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great,
great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great,
great, great, great, great, great, great, great,
great, great, great.
It's Cetera. Grandma of everybody in this room. It is true.
There was a creature down there. Um,
there was a creature down there.
I thought we should stop there because we were getting away with something and I
didn't want to push it too far. All of a sudden it was just Uli. Yeah.
Though there is a creature down there,
uh, in a, in a little hole. And when the dinosaurs got cleared away,
this creature could step out of her hole. She could step out of her niche.
She had more food, more places to roam.
She could populate the planet ushering in the age of mammals.
And now here we all are in Seattle.
Oh, don't flatter yourself. It's not a straight line. It's a weekly lie.
I do weekly.
Here's the problem.
We've never known anything about this animal that gave rise to all of us.
We've never known what you look like. We've never known, uh,
you know how she spent her days.
We never known anything because we've had no fossils of her.
But recently actually,
literally as we were reporting this story right in the middle of our reporting,
uh, a team of scientists led by a woman named Maureen O'Leary who is herself a
mammo. She took, uh,
fossils that we do have fossils of this creatures descendants and then using
fancy algorithms was able to cross reference the traits to work our way back for
the first time to a composite picture of what we think our great great-grandma
look like. So now Seattle, a Radiolab exclusive.
We present you our great, great, great,
great set her up grandma
here. A giant rodent costume thing runs out onto the stage. All right,
well this is what she looks like and we got to point out certain anatomical
features that caught the scientists admiration. First of all, she has very,
very pink and fleshy ears.
So show them bath and a pale soft underbelly English of all.
It's very nice for as Gad is now demonstrating,
could you show them your profile just so they can see your head?
First skull is considered either rat flight or a crocodilian.
You can go either way, but she does that enormous BB black eyes.
No fleshy pink nose. And would you show them your teeth?
She's kind of proud of her teeth because they can tear flesh,
they can rip medicine. She is an omnivore.
However, here was the issue.
You was the issue that we ran into when we asked Maureen and the scientist who
did this work. We were like, okay, now we've got an image of this creature.
That's amazing. What do we call her?
What is her name? This was Maureen's response.
Its official name is the hypothetical placental mammal
look kind of a name was back suddenly feeling bad for this little creature.
Well it's not something that we thought of as we were sort of busily working on
the paper,
but then a funny thing happened.
Our producer Molly was talking to marina and she was saying,
Jesus is such an awful name and marine system. Molly. Well,
you can name it. And Molly says to Marie, wait, are you serious in Maureen,
sister Molly? I don't know. Are you serious?
So
we're like, hell yeah, we're serious. Let's crowd sources, right?
This is what mammals do these days. We crowd source. I mean,
think of this opportunity. A little radio show gets the name,
the ancestor of us all. So we've put out the call to the Internet.
We've got the thousand submissions in response.
Great names like we'll send door first,
first surs de Nova,
and after eight rounds of voting, the winning name was, wait for it.
Wait
for it, wait for it
on the screen. You see the following letters appear one after another, s, c, h,
r, e, w, d, I, N, g, e, r,
shooting her,
shooting her.
I can't even tell you what a crisis was for the staff.
It's just such a bad day.
And the whole experience made us wonder, should we have died in that asteroid?
Do we deserve to be here?
[inaudible]
so if you're asking yourself, what is the moral of our story,
here's what we've shown you.
But we have a big mighty species that die and then a smaller species,
which is you and I, we take it's place.
So you've gotten death and you've gotten resurrection and you got it maybe in a
single afternoon. So that's the argument we're making here.
This is Jay Molossia's argument that it was boom.
I mean it is the suddenness of of the whole Bover that is kind of unimaginable.
I mean like I'm in,
there you are one day you have evolved over millions of years to be this long
neck, beautiful creatures,
70 feet from your nose to your ass and then our tail and then in an afternoon,
like on one Tuesday afternoon, suddenly you, everyone you knew gone.
But there are other ways to think about this. The extinction yes was sudden,
but in the grand sweep of time, it wasn't really an,
and it was just a moment in a stream of endless change.
Cause everything we see around us, the tallest mountains, the size of oceans,
the animals about us that seem so different from ourselves.
Every category that we have in our heads that seems so permanent,
blurs given enough time,
mountains erode and become a hills, that peaches,
animals changing any kind of all kinds of ways. The only thing that's constant,
it's always is changed. You like to think of ourselves.
We humans just somehow inevitable or crucial pivotal that the past was a time
and we were missing in the future. We'll always have us in it,
but that's an illusion. Since this great science writer, Lauren Isley,
we are rag dolls made out of many ages and skins. He says,
changelings who slept in witness or still the uncouth guys of waddling
amphibians. We've played such roles for infinitely longer ages than we had been.
Men. All right, entity is it dream
[inaudible]
we are process not reality.
What we call realities as Isley is an illusion of the day light,
the light of our own particular day.
[inaudible]
just a couple of notes before we go on. Uh,
that whole dinosaur thing about the sudden fast end. That is just a theory.
A verdict is obviously still out. In fact,
in 2011 a team of scientists published a paper saying that maybe the asteroid
that hit the earth created that devastation was not that distinct,
but another asteroid with a different name,
but with the same size and dimensions and all that. So who knows. Also,
when I said to the people up in the balcony, if you were in the balcony,
you might've been killed off by heat.
I think that turns out to be a little bit wrong.
If you've been in the shallow ocean of the day, he would have been acid rated.
Some other factors would have been not so much heat.
Okay, so this is the part of the show coming up where we, uh, we, we,
we traveled with a bunch of different comedians. Patton, Oswald, Simon Amstel,
Ophir Eisenberg, Kurt Braunohler, actually Kurt open this particular show.
You can see his full set at radiolab.org/live super funny.
But on this night we had two comedians.
And so right at this spot in the middle of the show, out walks a guy,
one of the most talented mammals he looks like.
Actually it's like someone with his finger in an electric socket.
Huge amounts of here that are standing like, ouch. You know,
like he's got a halo. His name
[inaudible].
We're just going to play his whole set.
It's a little Seattle specific and spots, but it's just, well, hello.
Hello,
hello, hello.
What I get done. And then
[inaudible] [inaudible] the month. Duh Duh. When a swell
[inaudible] flush. You can see the, I could eat a more
warm Rashida.
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
Yep, Yep, Yep.
Zoo my room.
Okay.
Wow. Microsoft
[inaudible]
thank you. Um, this is a,
this is a moment that you have to take, uh, if you can,
uh, and if you can't, uh, you know, then you've lost it. But,
um, once you have it, once you possess the moment, um,
you can do so many things with it. Um,
a lot of people tend to just exist within it. Um,
others pawn it off to moment brokers. Um, uh,
or if you're a big fan fan of moment. Shawn's, uh, um, you, um,
I can do that. Uh, also the moment, a moment, glory blend of coffee,
single origin from Argentina is excellent.
You can get that at most Bauhaus or participating in Stumptown coffee roasters.
Um, so definitely check that out.
I'm really stoked that we finally closed down that awful Bauhaus. Um,
coffee and books. It was just what a terrible location, right.
You know, right on a like a corner where you can see it really visibly. And, um,
I don't like that. Um, and, and I called the,
the city, the city comptroller and I just said, we need to get rid of it. Um,
and we need to get as many,
many buildings cause there's a lot of those buildings are so old up on Capitol
Hill, it's just, it gets, it gets old. Um,
and so I'd like to replace them with new constructions, um,
mostly glass and contemporary metal. Um,
and I want to be able to see the architect's idea and then see them have to
shave off about 40% of that idea.
Yeah.
By replacing a lot of the materials with cheaper versions of the original
design. Um,
I enjoy seeing that and I would rather see that than in a coffee shop that
promotes, um, a type of a communal, uh,
living that can only happen in an area that it is located in. I just prefer it.
That's what I prefer. That's just me.
Sorry guys.
That new building. Okay. Maria. My, my,
um, okay. So, um, obviously as you know, uh, Seattle is, is,
uh, is becoming their Cooper. And the thing is,
it's like
I'm going to do a song, um, that is about that.
So you guys can get a little bit more used to the, the Vancouver Culture, um,
that is spreading down
Canada, Canada.
Um, little, uh, uh, Mr. Rogers reference, but, um,
Canada is Atlanta may believe.
Okay,
here we go.
Okay.
Okay. Here we go. Any big fans of anybody born after 1990.
Okay. That's about the tonality you would expect.
[inaudible]
why is it always higher? I don't understand that. Um, okay.
Anyways, um, so you're gonna know this reference. This is a from the old, uh,
Buck Rogers, uh, series, uh, Biggie, Biggie, Biggie, g, Buck, you know,
that kind of stuff.
So that's where you guys after 1998 so you guys can relate to what I'm doing on
stage. And so,
um,
I hope you like this. This is, this is definitely, definitely a song.
Okay.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] a good moment.
[inaudible]
my own food.
[inaudible] who is
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] thank you very much.
Um, if you're, if you're down, um, at a, in, in,
in Ballard and having a good time, um, it's,
it's because there's so much Scandinavian energy there that,
uh,
they just do, they just do it. Right.
Um,
so when you hit the sunset tavern and you're like,
why isn't this turned into a glass tower?
It's because the power of Norway,
this is Norway. They're going to screw with that. You know what I mean?
Like Norway at all? No, what I'm saying,
there's no way out of this. I mean, you're basically, you know what I'm saying?
It's like a hot dog. You know, you think you want it and you're like, ah,
probably not. But,
um, and I'm pretty stoked I've said this before, but I,
I'm going to say it again just because we're in Seattle. I am pretty stoked, um,
about, uh, uh, Vivace um,
being replaced by a Starbucks. I just think that it makes sense. It makes sense.
Let the people who do it really well do it better. You know what I'm saying?
That's what I'm saying.
So this song is going to be one of those songs where you're going to think to
yourself, is this better than the original? Maybe. Okay.
Alright.
It's called pastiche in lieu of originality. Here we go.
Yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
don't want us to use real parents in the ones that come from, they miss them.
She didn't follow.
Okay,
Whoa, Whoa, whoa.
We need to know a logo. No
logo characters. [inaudible]
yeah.
Yay You.
The thing is,
a good thing is
I think
using, using, using logic. Um, I think,
you know, obviously it is smart to name a company after a,
a character from Battlestar Galactica, but I just,
it makes sense
and that's why I'm starting my own coffee business called cylons.
Cylons coffee is the best coffee.
I have a new movie coming out called silence of the lambs and,
um,
it's a theme song. It's done by Garfunkel and Oates. Of course.
You can probably guess what that song is called a the sound of silence and,
um,
which is just [inaudible]. Mm hmm.
And sometimes
and sometimes,
yeah,
it's the sound of silence. Okay. So,
um, this song, thank you for my next trip.
No, it's been a pleasure. This is my last, uh, Radicchio lab and I am
and I'll say no, in all seriousness. That's a totally different show,
but I'm radio lab. Um, it's been awesome, man. I mean, uh,
I discovered some really great friends the first time I did something, um,
for radio lab and I continue to find great friendships and a love and passion
for sound and um,
science and knowledge and art. And so I think that, um, I'm lucky,
lucky to be part of it in this small way that I answered. Thanks. Radio,
Radiolab, wherever you are.
Okay. So this is a, it's a quick song and it goes
okay.
Okay. And, uh, this song is,
this song is a, that's a, that's a good one.
Yeah. Okay.
Here we go.
[inaudible] okay.
Ooh.
[inaudible] yes.
[inaudible] [inaudible] Jeez.
[inaudible]
C and is nine years
[inaudible] du Du du Du du
[inaudible].
When I
[inaudible] walking cross this baron
[inaudible] baby,
I can gum blame when those chairs is gold chair into the sky.
Squawking with the laser precision swooping now on seeking breeze and knowing
that shining
little.in the distance is not a super extra shiny star on the astro physicist
dinosaurs would have said in that time.
[inaudible]
uh, Ben.
Oh boy. Yes. Arby's. Matt.
It was great to see the earth concoct his large lizard families,
those lizards made sounds and attacked each other and wore coats and clothing,
but oh well, all of that got burned off.
And the evidence of a natural intellectual society may not be apparent to us.
Whoa. I know. Yeah.
But what happened to the sleaze stacks?
What happened to Whoa, those slurping sleaze,
eggs moving and probably at top speed of three miles per hour or the aliens that
donated genetic material to the hominids in order to create the society people
that we are now.
This explains our fascination for diamonds and goals because we've just kind of
dug it up for their spaceships. Oh,
Yay.
[inaudible]
no, it means nobody. Nobody. Nobody. Nobody. Nobody. Nobody.
Nobody. Nobody. Nobody. Nobody. Nobody. Nobody. Nobody. Nobody. Nobody my age.
Nobody. Nobody. Nobody. Nobody.
[inaudible]
thank you so much guys.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
let's just take stock for a second. Robert,
we did our super fast radical dyno ending.
Reggie did his Reggie ending, which,
which you never quite sure what he's saying. You know?
Can you imagine we have scripts everything.
Imagine if I just want you open through the river
[inaudible]
all evening long. It would be outer space, man. Wow. Okay, so what's in the,
what's next? What's our next day?
Pink ending now. The pagan thing. You mean like the color? Yeah,
this is the one that answered,
I think the most basic question you could ask in a show like this. This asks,
when did endings begin?
It's a serious question. That's a weird one. When did endings begin? Wouldn't
they're always, I mean the moment you had beginnings,
wouldn't that then imply an end because the beginnings have to do something
and you'd think so,
but if you think hard about the origin of the universe, I would propose,
but when the universe began,
which by seminar [inaudible] was a huge explosion of energy,
which then condensed and cooled into matter that that whole event came in
without any notion of endings at all. Huh? When you get matter,
when you get that condensation,
you get a list of elements which we can now turn to in the periodic table of
elements with which you, I'm sure,
very familiar and enjoy every evening before dining or sleeping.
Keith here now puts the periodic table up on the screen. So if we,
if we look at this at this chart,
let me start up in the upper left hand side of the hydrogen and we move through
it. The helium and lithium and beryllium and Boron and carbon and on and on.
As we move through the list,
I can tell you that every one of the first 82 elements on this chart with two
exception, which I mentioned in a minute,
everyone of these has a version of itself that goes on forever and ever and ever
until the end of time. Every one of these you're saying is immortal.
Is that what you're saying? Yes. Now, here's the thing.
When we get to number 83 that's business.
I would argue that this is where the universe invents and things.
Really what is, what is bismuth?
It's a rock kind of a shiny black rock and you're saying this shiny black rock
is, is is, is where death begins? Yes. Yes.
I would say that that's a fair apply. Would that be well,
because all the atoms at the bottom of this chart are a little heavier than the
ones on the top, meaning they have lots and lots of of neutrons and protons.
Here. Keith brings up an image of a bismuth. Adam with lots of jiggling,
protons and neutrons. There's so many of them. As you can see,
they're having a little trouble holding their themselves together and French
scientists studying this. Adam recently determined that inevitably,
inevitably something will happen to this. Adam. It goes something like this.
Protons and neutrons fly off the Adam and amazingly Roberts pool was perfectly
timed in this case with Keith hitting the button to do it visually and that had
ever happened before. Wow. You tell him that so well do it again.
Do that again. Okay. I don't think I can do it twice. Well, no,
you don't add sound effects. I've know the side effects are you?
You do that one more time.
Oh No. Now you're like stripe. That made him angry.
Stop it.
That's the point I'm trying to make Keith, is that this Adam,
when it loses protons, it loses its identity. What an Adam decays it.
This Adam is no longer bismuth if it doesn't have the right number of proteins.
That's the way chemistry you were saying like as it as it shifts its protons and
neutrons. It's dying. That's right. Now here's the cool thing.
When we go back to the chart to number 83 every element after it po
[inaudible] descend rig elements 84 to one 18 also decay.
So on the periodic table you see two teams. Basically the ones at the top,
they're forever ours.
They go forever and on the bottom you have the ones that die, right?
That's correct, that's correct. But with the,
with the two exceptions I mentioned I should say 43 and 61 that's technium and
promethium. Nobody really likes those two
there.
I find them actually unnecessary. I'll tell what if they,
if they mess up the whole logic here, let's just it, let's just get rid of them.
Let's to get one of them. Get Out, get them out of here.
Okay.
We just spoke two holes into the table.
Let me just say when we've divided up like this,
now you can see that bismuth is APA dividing line. Maybe if the universe,
cause this is like this is what you see.
It's like the KT boundary with the dinosaurs. This is a, this is different.
Everything for everything. But the cute,
cool thing is business is pretty good for you. Really.
People swallow a little bits of business every time they get tummyaches to do
this all the time. You recognize this color. Maybe screen fills with pink. Yeah,
pink. I mentioned [inaudible].
Do you recognize the product associated with this color?
You know this product, pepto Bismol. Yeah, but just say it right?
Say it the way it should be. Said pepto. What did I say? What bismal no, no.
Say the only, the first syllable pepto is, are you applying the [inaudible]?
You're applying the Bismol stands for business. I don't have to imply it's true.
There's a pepper blue tines bismuth.
I don't know Robert and I was with you right up until this point,
but if I had to guess,
I would say that Bismol is just the name of the dude that made pepto B j Jake f
abysmal. You know, I'm telling you that each bottle of pink liquid,
there are little black rocks and, and that's just the truth. I don't know.
I don't know if prove it to you. Relevant to me.
Now that I hear Robert Appears on the screen in chemistry goggles,
you know, laboratory with a chemistry teacher by my time in Brooklyn.
And what you then see us do is we take in tablets of Pepto B.
We Mush them up with a mortar and pestle. We add some water,
we add some hydrochloric acid, we shake it some aluminum,
and you get to see little bits of black rock precipitate out of the pepto
bismal. Lots of them. I was surprised at how much black stuff is in there.
And then I showed the test tube to Jack Jad. Look,
you can't deny scientific fact at hiding inside every single pepto bismal tablet
is pure street-level grade crystal business
in the side, pepto B.
You will find an element that not only cures Tommy eggs fairly and introduces
death to the universe. I think it's such a great element.
We should have a toast to business. Yeah, it's ever toast. Okay.
Okay.
Can we close the segment by both of us taking two big pint glasses,
filling them up to the top within pepto Bismol and chugging
[inaudible].
You always did it faster just by a hair.
So special thanks to Gail Carnow,
my chemist Sam keen who helped write this thing. Lauren swarthout who got us,
he got us the lab connection and Zach Fan and who shot it,
edited it and re edited it and re edited it
and radio lab fashion
is there. Now we will pause only to do some business
[inaudible].
This is Darren gray from on
Fillmore and Radiolab is supported by next issue providing unlimited access to
popular magazines like wired, Vogue, rolling stone, people, fitness,
popular science and over 100 more all for a single price.
Listeners can read as much as they want,
all in one convenient app and try one month free at next issue.com/radiolab
hi, this is Kurt Brown.
All are from the stage or the paramount theater in Seattle, Washington.
Radiolab is supported by Tablo software helping people see and understand their
data.
Tableau lets people connect to any kind of data and visualize it on the fly
databases, spreadsheets,
and even big data sources are easily combined into interactive visualizations,
reports and dashboards.
What is your data trying to tell you for your free trial?
Visit Tablo software@tableausoftware.com slash Radiolab
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hey, I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab and we're going to go back now to the final segment
in our show about endings recorded live at the paramount theater in Seattle.
All right,
we're going to close the show. We're going to shift the mood a bit.
We're going to close out this show and our tour with a very different kind of
ending. Yeah. Cause unlike dinosaurs, you know,
dinosaurs have no idea what's ever going to happen to them.
But in this story we have an ending in which the enders can see what's coming.
It's coming right at them. Not Fast, but in this case very slowly.
So can you guys hear me easily? Easily. Okay, good.
We'll introduce you to two guys. Chris Jones and Dan Moran.
They both actors in Manhattan, both been doing it 30, 40 years,
30 40 years, plays movies, you name it. Uh,
five 40 arm.
Tom's body gassers pantomime circus tune season on Broadway downtown.
Moonstruck the share moving Shakespeare.
There are a lot of comedies.
He worked pretty much everywhere there is to work as it happens.
I know this story cause Chris, one of the actors is an old friend.
We met in a high school musical actually many years ago.
Oklahoma. You think everything is Oklahoma? I didn't know.
I don't know anything goes.
Mm.
Our story for both Chris and Dan begins 10 years ago
[inaudible]
Dan was onstage, big stage, Washington,
D C I was doing streetcar as a streetcar named desire.
He was playing the lead role. Stanley Kowalski.
You know the guy that Marlon Brando made famous for yelling, Hey,
that guy,
the woman playing Stella said it's really sexy how your left arm doesn't swing
when you walk. It's kind of like animalistic. I said, well that's cool.
So I used it.
You thought, all right, if it works, it works.
I'll just play the character that way is the guy whose arm doesn't swing.
But I, after the show ended, I was walking down the street in Manhattan.
I thought, why isn't my left arm swing? What's going on?
Oh Chris.
So right out of around the same time he was in Delaware shooting a film,
a movie by
m night Shambhala, kind of a great movie.
[inaudible] called the village marks.
I played Adrian Brody, his father, and we're getting ready in wardrobe.
One day he noticed that
and I had a slight tremor,
occasionally difficult time buttoning buttons with my right hand.
I thought I had a pinched nerve in my neck.
I went to see an orthopedic guy and he said, you should see a neurologist.
I went to um, a doctor and he said,
very gleefully, I think you've got Parkinson's.
And he had to run a deficit in the Parkinsonian that he's pleased.
He was able to help me out. He nailed it.
Now Parkinson's, if you ask an expert,
which we did,
Cheryl Waters, Columbia University Medical Center,
Parkinson's is a very mysterious disease.
I'm not sure what to think about it now because it keeps evolving and changing.
Some people, according to Dr. Waters, when they get the disease,
nothing happens, nothing.
They come with tremor and they die with a little bit of tremor and nothing else
ever happens. But in other cases for some reason it could wreak havoc
because sometimes, and doctors really don't know why this is the case.
Sometimes the disease will just start to march through the brain.
It'll begin deep down,
low down and the brainstem and then it will gradually inch its way upward.
First of all, detect this little cluster of cells in the middle of the brain,
that control movement and that's when you start to see the shakes and then
little by little there's a progression progression up a migration to the surface
to other areas of the brain that control thinking, memory,
concentration and in those cases the disease,
it is an extra bleak progressive.
So you got these different kinds of Parkinson's one that sleeps one day it
goes on the rampage.
The problem is when you're diagnosed you can never quite be sure which kind you
got because for the people in whom it spreads,
it can take decades. When he you have Parkinson's,
did you feel like you
no trouble at the time it was a joke. It was a joke. This is nothing.
I'm fine.
In the beginning,
Dan and Chris didn't really worry a whole lot about this cause they didn't have
to. In fact, Chris, when I first was diagnosed and was performing,
he was doing a lot of Shakespeare and you'll,
if his hand never started to to shake a bit.
It was always nice to have a nice big cloaker Cape for me to wear to hide my
hand bind so that the audience wouldn't see the tremor.
Truth is it didn't happen. All that often wasn't much of a deal.
Chris kept acting.
Dan kept acting and in both of them their Parkinson's seemed to be the kind that
stays asleep for two years,
three years, five years, seven years,
but then after eight years
[inaudible]
just woke up.
I just found out that it got her and a hundred a moon dances.
He's not quite sure when it happened,
but suddenly his limbs were aching all the time.
That easy control that you have over your body as you're walking down the street
where all the limbs are moving together and you don't have to think about it for
him but started to disappear.
You'd have to think about each leg, each foot, independently, left foot,
right foot, left heel,
right here to Chris.
He would actually have these moments where he would try to move his arm where
his brain would basically say to his arm, Woo,
but his arm would just sit there and stark like it wanted to move.
It just somehow couldn't. I would freeze on stage.
It was a nightmare
and as things progressed,
Dan would have these moments in rehearsals where suddenly you would just go
blank.
I had done this TV show on FX.
I had one scene where I couldn't remember five lines, I just couldn't remember.
Five lines. We chuck all night.
I got my interests. We would do lines and come back out and blow it.
Now this isn't an easy situation for anybody, but if you're an actor,
if you're somebody who has to inhabit a character,
the different rhythm than yours and different flow, use your body to do that,
which is how you pay the rent. For actors.
Parkinson's is just awful because it kills their craft. Oh,
your face becomes a mask so you haven't got your face and without face you don't
have flow. The way I like in it,
if you take a pebble and you throw it into a pool of water, it goes
and there's a ripple that goes. Just concentric circles go out from the impact.
If you take me my body,
my self as an actor and you throw a pebble into my pool,
it goes thud. There's no fluidity. There's no,
it just stops. I once I,
I opened up to the acting world. I had Parkinson's,
my agent strapped me,
the calls pretty much stopped calling and that was that.
But then one night something happened
[inaudible]
how did this idea come up? Well,
it was my first idea and I guess your brilliant idea. Thank you buddy.
And we should say that these two guys, Chris and Dan,
they've actually known each other for years. The two of you met doing what?
Among the thin country, which is a classic play on Broadway and Dan explains,
it was late one night he was having insomnia,
which is the usual side effect of the medication he has to take.
And he was just looking around for something to read and he grabs this play off
the shelf. It was a play by Samuel Beckett,
the play in one act, and he starts reading characters have clove.
I mean this was a play that he knew he had read it before,
but that night it seemed to talk to him in a way that was totally new.
Their interior gray light right from the start.
It started off with a guy shuffling on stage.
Clove goes and stands under the window, left stiff, staggering walk,
shuffling around. He looks up at the window left.
He turned to looks to window right. And I said, well yeah, I know shuffling.
He thought, I feel this guy can't sit, can't get comfortable,
seem familiar to him. And then on the next page, hamsters,
another guy interests the scene, very red face, black glasses,
also in bad shape. This guy is stuck in this wheelchair. Can't walk anymore.
He takes off his glasses. Why exercise is faced with the glasses,
puts them on again. So here you got these two guys, one can't sit,
one can't stand.
They're stuck in this little room with these two windows that look out and
outside those windows either due to an asteroid,
a nuclear holocaust, what used to be green is now gray,
like a wasteland.
Is there anyone alive out there do you think or no? No.
Outside their window. They can see the ocean but it seems to stop moving.
There are no waves now in game
and
that's a term that comes from the chest and it refers to that moment in the game
when they're just a few pieces and just a few moves left the last few moves
before the inevitable outcome. It's not the end.
It's the point right before the add.
And it's the place where you become aware of the end for the first time.
And dinosaur can't do that. But these two characters,
they've run out of everything out of painkiller.
Painkillers are gone out of biscuits and they have that awful awareness and now
they have to deal with it. Like here we are. What do we do?
How
do we fill up the time on this rock hurtling through space?
The more I read it,
it just felt like Parkinson's to me being locked in a room with my body.
I'm not getting out. There's no killer. I'm not getting out of this room.
And then on page three, one of the characters,
a guy named Pam stops what he's doing and he says, enough.
It's time it ended
and yet
I hesitate.
I hesitate to end and dance is something about the line and yet I hesitate.
I hesitate to to end just flipped a switch for him.
Screw these people that won't hire me
[inaudible]
because I've got this fucking little disease that makes me shake or talk funny.
I don't need those people. No. The next morning he calls Chris.
Chris described the call,
you're sitting there and one day the phone rings was that it was happening.
He says, how'd you like to get together and take a look at end game?
Christian remembers thinking. I don't know. I'm not sure if I'm up to it.
It's a 70 minute long play.
It's gotten 12,000 words and material is monumental, but they,
I know that let's just, no pressure. Let's just,
let's just meet at each other's apartments. So one day Dan would read one part,
Chris, the other part, the next day they'd switched.
And they did this for almost a year. The two of them each other's living rooms,
reading the play back and forth until finally they contacted the Becca the state
and got permission to put on one live performance in New York.
We decided Chris is having more trouble with his movement than I am.
I'm more trouble with my speech and Chris's. So I thought,
well why don't I take on the part with all the speech and you got all the
moving. So will you do the whole movement? That makes sense.
You both leaned into your weaknesses. Yes. Well,
so the obvious question is why would two people in danger and in more danger
over time,
why would you decide to spend time staring at that danger straight in the eye?
Like that's just a weird thing to do. It's the only and do it.
That's the only way to do it. I can't like go through my,
that's my life being afraid of this fucking disease.
When he said that I didn't quite understand what he was saying cause if you are
legitimately afraid of something,
why would it make you less afraid to stare at it's details?
That would make me more afraid. I mean I don't know if it's about fear really.
I think it's about knowing, knowing what, knowing
no one where you are. Like where are you really are, you know?
It's like a kind of journalism in a way.
Like I could imagine if you've got this thing that's been stealing from me for
10 years, right? It's stealing your body.
It's steering your craft at a certain way. You want to know like where am I?
Am I in my past? It is the end already happen for me.
Am I broken or do I have something left?
I mean it's sorta like in one of the back of plays,
not this one but an earlier one.
Their character waltz is on the stage and he says the following two sentences,
I can't go on. I will go on. It's like there's two sentences. Contradiction,
right. I can't go on and I will go on.
It's almost as if Dan is trying to figure out which sentence is he? Is he the,
I can't. Is it done or is he the,
I will like he's got something left and the only way to know that is to look at
the thing that's posing the question. Boom.
What if you put on the play and you find that you get the wrong answer?
You find out I can't. Here's what Chris was worried about.
The big issue for me was what happens to my sense of myself if we get to the
performance stage of this project and it turns out,
mm,
no, like I couldn't cut it
and yet they go on
[inaudible]
after a year of reading this play back and forth in their living rooms,
Chris and Dan decide, okay, it's time to find a performance space.
Time to hire a director. Oh.
They used to come dragging their asses into rehearsal.
Looking like these guys are going to be able to go from here to there.
That's yoga. Fozzy Chris and dance director, shaky and Wigley is,
I used to call him. He's known him for years. You did not call him back.
Oh you know cause that's what they were doing.
It just says Dan and Chris were two of the best actors he has ever worked with
and oddly enough in this case their disease could be an asset.
I believe that because they're halfway home,
they could feel what Beckett's characters in this play were feeling better than
anyone.
I never felt for a moment this wasn't going to make the play better if they
could get through rehearsals, easier said than done.
Take the problem with a medication. Now both of them,
when they're peaking on their meds, they are sharpen their clear focus,
but when the meds start to taper away, they get clouding too.
The hope was if they were going to rehearse together, they some have to,
they'd have to time it just right so that they pop their pills at the right time
and rise together, get clear,
and then taper off together at the same time. The
medication gives you about an hour and a half window.
Might be just enough time to run a few seeds. Problem was,
it wouldn't always work. I'd somebody I'd walk in and Dan says,
even when it's time to just, right. Sometimes the medication wouldn't take,
I would be completely locked up and Chris would be right in the middle of a
scene doing really well and then gets so tired you'd have to sit down.
Didn't have much stamina, so it's like that's just turn around,
go home or break out the mattresses. Sometimes Joe says they actually did.
We lay around on the floor or we just do something like you'd lay around on the
floor. Yeah. I said, let's lay down. Let's,
why don't we lay down and do the lines laying down.
That's actually a great exercise point is that a lot of times rehearsals were a
bust and as they got closer and closer to the performance day, Dan would say,
take me aside and say, you know, I got to tell you Joe is okay,
but I'm scared out of my mind, you know, scared out of my mind.
This would became terrifying and I,
well that's good if you know who we are since when shouldn't we be scared right
then and then. Then he'd remind Dan of a basic law of the theater.
Terrible rehearsals, make great performances and most of the time,
but they knew this was a very different situation.
Very different words. 15 oh,
thank you baby. Then came July 13th last year.
The people are coming the night of the performance.
Uh,
Rosie. Yeah. You got our understudies
couple minutes before the show.
Dan Calls for the so-called understudies and then runs to the back door to smoke
a cigarette.
I'm looking up this door and having shit why looked out and half suit many times
before everything seems familiar.
Bye.
I don't belong there. I feel like I, I feel like I'm
okay.
Like what am I doing here? He says, he kept thinking,
how did I think I could do this? I mean I'm going to fuck it up.
I'm going to forget lines. I'm not the character. I'm not,
I'm not fully the character. I haven't rehearsed enough.
I haven't had enough rehearsal time.
And he says he actually walked out the door,
got about halfway out cause he's at that moment he was thinking, you know that,
I mean that question, can I or can I?
I've got my answer and I'm about to go out in front of hundreds of people and
show them nakedly. Then I am broken that I can't do this.
Does the end has already happened.
Then he thought, I've started this ball rolling
and I couldn't stop it. So no,
just do what you have to do. Just start at the beginning.
Go until the end and then the stop
[inaudible]
okay. So the play begins with Dan in the middle of the stage.
He's asleep in a wheelchair, covered by a sheet. Chris Paces around behind him,
sort of shuffles about, looks out those windows mumble.
It's got it off. Okay. Chris was very worried about getting a little loud,
Huh?
For sound. He makes, he gets a laugh right from the start. The audience,
God Beckett's humor. That was a great,
great relief.
But then the thing Dan feared most happened in one of the big speeches of the
play. You went blank.
Oh my God. What's my next line?
I lost the line.
He says he's stared down at his feet for 20 seconds and then his wife fed him a
line and he went on. That was one moment,
but there was another moment,
a series of moments actually that were entirely different.
It began fish.
This fish just after Chris is opening monologue,
Stan begins to speak John de be misery
loftier than mine.
I tried my damnedest to just stay with the story moment by moment.
Enough. It's time.
It ended in the shelter too and yet I hesitate.
I hesitate to to n yes,
there it is. It's time and anything I hesitate.
Dan says as he was up there making that speech,
that speech about how it's time to end and yet he hesitates.
A funny thing happened, you know my performance muscles started to take over.
His body loosened up his legs, his arms, his mouth.
Suddenly they were under his control in a way they hadn't been for months.
He could move them without thinking.
It's a quite remarkable call. Yes. Have you not had enough?
We were able to do things on stage of what?
For this huge stretch of the plate. It was like the disease was gone.
That's always the lay at the end of the day, isn't it closed? Always.
It's the end of the day. Like any other day, isn't it? Close login.
What's happening? What is happening? Something is taking its course
and then there we are. That's enough.
It was over
[inaudible]
he was amazing.
And then I know we were walking back stage and Kristen, I just burst into tears.
Well you just don't cry.
It was not so much about the release of doing it,
but I think and more to do with family,
our kids and our why.
And some really good friends could see that
still
some kind of possibility.
And I do believe that it was mixed with feeling like, Oh God,
I'm going to miss this. For me,
a lot of times when I commit to a project,
one of the things that I'm sort of curious about is who will I meet in the
person of me in this project?
Ooh,
who will I find in the room when I, when I work on the material?
And
I was pretty proud of
[inaudible]
who I found on this one.
There's something in this story that
it speaks to all the things we feel about endings. I mean,
obviously it hurts.
It hurts to end is as Dan says,
and this is the line that gets me every night. Oh God, I'm gonna miss this.
But there's also something in with Chris's that if you stare unblinkingly at the
truth, you sometimes find something in yourself that you hadn't seen before,
which is in its way a new beginning.
And so it's time now it's time to end. You know,
we've never quite figured out how to end this show about endings except maybe to
follow Dan's simple advice and start at the beginning. Go until the end,
then stop. Yeah. And so ladies and gentleman, we've started at the beginning.
We've gone at the end and now we will stop.
Hm.
I'd like to go on a little bit longer. A little bit.
All right then Reggie, take us out.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
this moment right here, this moment,
no one had a better view of this moment than me because I'm sitting there behind
a desk. You get out from the desk, walk to the side of the stage,
get the hyper-realistic T-rex,
dinosaur masterfully puppeteered by Mr Myron Cuso.
And you guys have like a break dance dance off in the middle of the stage.
2,500 people just do not know what they're looking at because they're seeing
Robert Krulwich bust a move. I mean like busted move in that like, you know,
Young Mc like 1995 way busting move. It's like, it's amazing.
It's so amazing in fact that you have to go to the website right now,
radiolab.org/live and watch it.
I also shot multiple videos from behind the stage cause I was like,
I cannot even see this. It was so,
it was the most joyful thing about it
and I want to thank you for that, Robert,
for allowing me to watch you do that night after night and for Reggie for
creating the music and for Sarah Upstate Darren, Greg Lynn Coachy,
Keith scratch. It was just awesome. It was awesome.
That plus the musical apocalypse. I will never forget those moments.
I also want to thank our sound geniuses,
Jill de bluff and Dave Sanderson and Dylan Keith and to our tireless fearless
and fear inspiring tour manager,
Melissa O'Donnell and to the woman without who any of this would have been
possible. Our director, Eleanor [inaudible],
I remember kroitch. Thanks for listening.
[inaudible]
hit row one, seat 10. Are you ready? Yes.
Apocalyptic. Oh, was performed live at the paramount theater in Seattle,
Washington by Robert Krulwich Jad ABIM Rod, Kurt Braunohler,
Reggie Watts, Miriam Guso, Glenn Coachee,
Daring Grey is Sarah lip state, Keith's scratch. Um,
our production team was Melissa O'Donnell and Tom Jefferts. Joel do both.
Dave Sanderson, Keith Scratch and Ellen Horn,
scenic invideo designed by Josh Higginson and Adam Schwitzer for workhorse and
game by Samuel Beckett.
Presented it through special arrangement with George Burkhardt Inc on behalf of
the estate of Samuel Beckett, all rights reserved. Thanks. Oh,
special thanks to outback concerts. Nick Noosa Foro,
Ruth crush got married. Beth Code,
old gym burn field and Kendra Snyder. Wow.
No, right.
That was a minefield of proper nouns of you got through it.
Also, while we're, while we're in the thinking, dude,
I want to think a in the NPR music team for so graciously agreeing to videotape
this performance for us to thanks to those guys with the cameras
he's see flipped around Radiolab. I was
supported in part by the national science and by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public understanding of science and
technology in the modern world.
More information about sloan.org radio lab is produced by W NYC and distributed
by NPR radio.
Lad is hope radio lab is hosted by Jad ABIM Rad.
Our staff includes Ellen Horn, Soren Wheeler, Pat Walters,
Tim Howard, parental Pharell, Molly Webster,
Melissa Odonnell, Jamie York, Dylan, Keith, Lynn Levy,
and Andy Mills with help from Matt Kelty, Kelsey Padgett,
Aryana whack, Damian Marchetti, and of course,
Scott Brown doing pro pro bono credit [inaudible] citation tonight.
That's huge. You know, you're right. Hey, give it up for Scott Brown.